Anthony is it true you try to recreate
the guardian's volume to music video but
failed failed miserably okay would you
like to discuss that uh yeah I really
happened yeah we were on set I pitched
an idea of us doing it and it just it
didn't come together well everybody
Chris Evans kind of took the idea and
ran with it and then forgot about it and
then it just fell apart and then
everybody just got busy what would you
have participated in this dance video if
you've been asked to do it no he said no
he said no he would never even got asked
give me that that's the oldest thing in
the evidence you say no but your people
say oh we're not even gonna go to him
over there no oh this thing I do that
alright Dan so I could dance yeah cut a
rug it's that cool who would be the
worst Anthony the worst dancer yeah hmm
Cheadle he's awful dancer we had a
dance-off before we were on Broadway
together and we were doing this play put
on some music had a dance-off wasn't a
good look real ghetto story that was
oddly beautiful yes yes thing you wanted
to say yeah you just made a very I
didn't know what he was I didn't know
what why you said why you sang realto
story and then I look to you just be
like and I was distracted by what you
were doing excuse to get confused we are
in a hotel room
you know it's really not look at this is
that bad that I did that good some poor
intern is like my work
[Laughter]
you